la pilule pour hommes un sujet qui
faisait déjà débat dans les années 60
ans
vous l'apprendrez liés au oui absolument
sur wii pour deux raisons moi je vous
dis c'est simplement bien pour les pays
sous-développés jeu contre l'épidémie
cieux pourquoi parce que maintenant que
faire l'amour sans les pilules à cette
époque les premières recherches
médicales émergeait alors quelques
années seulement après la légalisation
en france de la pilule féminine
concernant la production des
spermatozoïdes on a pensé pouvoir
trouver des hormones
exactement comme chez la femme qui
bloquerait soit la fabrication des
spermatozoïdes eux mêmes soient les
gonadotrophines de l'hypophyse qui comme
chez la femme stimule le testicule pour
produire les spermatozoïdes
le sujet était aussi évoquée dans des
émissions de débats
exemple ici sur le plateau de l'émission
aujourd'hui madame ce médecin présentait
différentes alternatives contraceptive
pour les hommes la pilule en faisait
partie mais selon lui sa généralisation
n'était pas pour demain
question de viril mais donner à des
hommes quelque chose en leur disant ça
va supprimer votre fonction spermato
génétique en face à va vous empêcher
d'avoir des enfants
ils vont comprendre que ça va les rendre
impuissant et je crois que c'est ça qui
a empêché le développement de la pilule
bascule et effectivement quelques années
plus tard dans les années 80 la pilule
était encore associé à une perte de
virilité jamais pourquoi qui n avaient
pas pourquoi parce que toute la vie un
manque d'engouement qui n'encourageaient
pas non plus les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques à investir dans le
développement de la pilule en 1980 2
pour démystifier la contraception
masculine un centre de consultation et
d'information ouvrait ses portes à
colombes en région parisienne
les spermatozoïdes sont fabriqués au
niveau du testicule
jusqu'ici les deux comprimés que l'on va
donner vont supprimer cette fabrication
à cette époque la pilule pour homme
était toujours au stade expérimental
seuls quelques membres de l'armée comme
l'association pour la recherche et le
développement de la contraception
masculine acceptait de jouer les cobayes
pour eux prendre la pilule était alors
un acte militant mais pour nous c'était
une démarche qui étaient importantes
pour partager la responsabilité de la
contraception avec nos partenaires et
assumée avec elle le désire ou le nom d
un enfant aujourd'hui la pilule
masculine fait toujours l'objet d'essais
cliniques cinquante ans après les
premières expérimentations
pourtant les français semblent plus
réceptifs à cette contraception en 2012
un sondage du csa révélait que 61% des
hommes se disait prêt à prendre la
pilule
[Musique]